So now we've figured out a way on how to lock the door.
Let's figure out a way to say, okay, it's locked, yes.
How do we now create it open at run time so that not only by before we jump in the
game deciding if they're locked, depending on a certain action, how can I then open
a door?
So I'm just going to delete the second door, I don't need that now, and I'm going
to create a button to press for the door that then says this is now unlocked.
So we want to create a new blueprint for this, so I'm going to open my quickdraw, I'm going
to hit control space bar, I'm going to right click, I'm going to create a blueprint class
like we did before, I'm going to select actor like we did previously, I'm still going
to call this BP underscore, and I'm going to call this button.
So BP underscore button, hit enter, I'm going to hit enter again, and it's already at the
top of my window here.
Now I want to find a mesh for my button, so I'm going to hit control and space bar,
I'm going to scroll down to my starter content, I'll go to props, and I'll just
find something that looks button like I could, I could use this mesh here, I could use
a corner frame, I think right now I'm just going to use this as my button, this corner
frame, this looks like a good button to use.
So I'm going to click add, I'm going to go to static mesh, and again because
I selected the corner frame we can see it there, so we'll add that there.
So we've got our static mesh in place, now I want to go and add a box component
again, exactly how we did with our door, so you'll see we're clicking very similar
buttons as we did last time, and you kind of get into the flow creating these
blueprints, so box collision here, we want to create a box collision, and we'll
again change the scale of this box so that we make sure we are well within
the radius of creating the box, that's going to be the front of my switch on
this front side here, so the box doesn't really need to go into the
wall, so I'm going to drag it out like that a little bit, I'm going to compile
and I'm going to save, I'm going to go back into my first person map, maybe
let's put this button on this back wall here, so we want to scroll up to
where our interactions are, I want to find the button, let's put this button nice
in the dead center of this wall here, so we can see the button, got plenty of
radius for the player to be walking into the button, that looks good, I'm going to
move this door over here just for when I'm testing, it's going to make things a
little bit easier, not wasting your time just running over the map, I'm going
to move my player start here, I'm going to rotate this around, you don't need to do
this, I'm just going to make it quicker for us to debug and playtest, I'm
going to file, save all here, and now how do we add functionality, so if we
think about our list of criteria that we want to do, this door is locked, we know
it's locked because it's got a tick box, so that's locked, now we want to somehow
say to this bool, just turn to false don't we, that's essentially what we're
looking at here, so we want this button to say to this blueprint, false, so
let's see how we can make that work, so we want to go into the button, again
we'll do a begin overlap and an end overlap, so we're in our button, we'll
go to our event graph, I'll just delete any of the existing content here, it's
not really needed, again renaming is good, so I'm going to rename this box
button overlap, just so we know, again just naming convention, you don't need to
do this yourself, I'm going to scroll down, I'm going to create a begin
overlap event, as we did with the door, I'm going to select the button again, I'm
going to create an end overlap, I'm going to right-click, I'm going to get
the player controller, so get player controller, same way that we did it
before, we want to enable input, and again we want to drag down, I'm just
holding ctrl on my keyboard as a reminder, so I'm dragging down enable
input, I'm going to disable the input, holding ctrl I'm going to drag down, or
you can break the link, do it yourself, there we go, so we got a begin overlap
and end overlap, I'm just going to compile and save, we want our interact button,
so interact, which is there, now this is where we run into a stumbling block, so
what do we want to do, we know we can enable the interaction on this button
and we know we can interact with this, if I test it out and say print string
and we just say you know button pressed exclamation mark, I'll only do two exclamation
marks this time instead of three, there we go, so if I go over to this, okay so
I'm pressing E, you can see button press, so we know we've got our basic
functionality, same functionality that we added to the door, we've got on the
the button on the wall now, now we need to figure out how we're
communicating with this door, now the best way I like to do this is I'm just
going to compile and save, I'm going to create a new variable, I'm going to
call this door ref, so D O O R capital R for ref and then call it ref, I'm going
to hit enter, what I'm going to do is from the boolean menu, I'm going to type
BP underscore door and you'll see I can create a variable which is my
blueprint, and so it's a bit hard to see the options here just because I'm in
blueprint class, you don't need to click off this but I'm just going to move
into some better space to be able to show you here, you'll see BP door you can
create an object reference, now that would work in and of itself if you ever
created an object reference, that's fine to do, I'm going to create a soft
object reference because it's just the cleaner way to work and the sooner you
can start thinking about the clean workflow the better, so I'm going to
create a soft object reference, I'm going to compile and save, I'm going to
drag out the door reference, I'm going to hold ctrl and get, now you'll see that
there's a turquoise looking pin here, I'm going to drag out and type resolve
so R E S O resolve, hit enter, now that turns into a blue pin which is
great for us, now we've got a reference to the blueprint door, if I hover over
here it says blueprint door, now what reference do I want to get, now if I
compile and save this the reference that I'm trying to get is is locked, I
want to speak directly to this variable, so in the blueprint I'm going to type is
locked, as soon as I start typing this you'll see that I have a variable
that says set is locked, now previously we've only done get before,
we've only got a variable, now we want to set the variable, we want to set the
locked state to be false, so let's click set, let's drag up here, let's press this
and is locked false now, so if I look at my map and it's ticked true, is locked
true, on my button I'm going to set is locked to false and let's just double
check that it works by adding a print string as we've done before, I'm going to
say door unlocked and now I can do three exclamation marks because that's
pretty pretty exciting moment in our level if we can get this door unlocked
let's save, let's go back into our map and let's press play, let's run over here
let's just check our door first, we press E on the door, door does nothing, let's
go over here, door unlocked three exclamation marks, now when we go over
and we press E, the door does not open, so that that's an issue let's fix it
that was not as exciting as I intended it to be, but let's have a look here what's
going on, so this is a great first tutorial and it's almost like I I did
this intentionally just as a good teaching moment, so what we'll see here
is access none and it actually doesn't know what door it's talking to at the
moment, so very easy to fix but let's just file, save all, let's make sure we
got our door working, now the thing that I didn't do here is I created a door
reference, I said door say is locked, no we don't want the door locked and we want
the door to be unlocked, now it doesn't actually know what door we're looking
to here, so let's go back into our first person map and you'll see that
when we select the door and we scroll down, can we see our default
properties, so what we've not done first is exposed it, so again like we
did on this one let's expose the variable, so let's expose the variable
because we want to create a reference, let's also give it a default property
let's say let's call these button properties, instead of the door properties
let's call this button properties, so let's compile and save, so we've set
our properties so we're looking for button properties, again it doesn't
matter what name you give that, the important thing is here is that we
expose the variable, so we've exposed the variable, we've compiled, we've saved
now when we click on our button we've got button properties, we've got door
reference, but it doesn't know what door it's speaking to, if I had loads of doors
in this map, again you don't need to do this, but if I had loads of doors in
this map, that button does not know which door it's speaking to, let's go to
pick connector from the scene, we'll do a little pipette here and we'll click
this door, now it knows it's talking to that door, now this door is just called
BP door, this door here is called BP door 2, now you don't need to do this
but if I pipetted this door here, it's a BP door 2, so you know which door
you're speaking to here, so let's let's just pipette that door, so we know
we're speaking to this door, let's save all just in case anything breaks,
let's jump in the game, now we should be able to get this three
exclamation marks, so let's see if we can achieve this, now we press E, the
door doesn't open, we say door unlocked exclamation mark, now let's see if this
door opens, we'll run over, we'll press E, hey the door's opened, and so now we've got
some very complex functionality, where we've got a button opening a door to
progress through the level, and there's some quite complex scripting, we've
created a new button class, again it's pretty similar to the door but we've
added some door referencing functionality, we're setting some bools and we've
figured out how to communicate between two blueprints.